In "Andor," the planet Ferrix is a hotbed
of activity leading up to Maarva Andor's funeral.
Imperial forces land on the planet as rebel
agents huddle, and the whole town is abuzz
with preparations.
In a shot of a local bar early in Episode
12, a smaller patron is seen walking back
to a table where their drink is waiting.
It's dark in the bar, and the shot only lasts
for a couple of seconds, but the alien appears
to be the same species as Maz Kanata.
The bar-goer has the same stature, head shape,
and even similar goggles to Maz, making this
seem like an intentional Easter egg.
"Andor" already has a vaguely similar alien
in the doctor who tries to save Nemik in Episode
6, but that character is pretty clearly a
different species.
The alien on Ferrix, on the other hand, looks
to be exactly the same kind of creature as Maz.
Of course, since we still don't know the name
or history of that species, this little cameo
remains shrouded in mystery.